ruth bader ginsburg came to the supreme
court not just as another
federal judge she reflected women's
emergence as
fully equal members of american society
in the late 20th century
she became kind of a progressive and
liberal icon a cultural figure
so her departure represents not just a
loss for liberals but kind of a deep
psychological blow for them as well
as a young woman she witnessed the
mccarthy hearings in the united states
and the electrocution of
rosenbergs and she viewed those days as
very dark and very bad for a democracy
and has said that she
decided to become a lawyer in part
because she saw a lawyer standing up for
people who were being targeted by the
government
in those ancient days i went to
cornell university there were four
men to every woman so for parents
of girls it was the ideal place
because if you couldn't find a man at
cornell you were hopeless
she was a woman who scaled heights in
the legal world before women
tended to do those sorts of things she
herself
litigated a series of sex discrimination
cases in the early 1970s
and persuaded this all-male court to
really change the way the law looked at
women
women today face discrimination in
employment
as pervasive and more subtle
than discrimination encountered by
minority groups
this absolute exclusion based on gender
per se
operates to the disadvantage of female
workers
their surviving spouses and their
children
constitutional safeguard is guaranteed
to all and it may be relied upon
by every person when she herself joined
the supreme court
she brought that spirit that idea
that the law has to grow to recognize
the way that society itself
is growing became a hallmark of her
jurisprudence i have had the great good
fortune to share life
with a partner a man who believed at
age 18 when we met that
a woman's work
[Music]
whether at home or on the job
is as important as a man's
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg took the judicial oath this
past friday
probably the case that she is proudest
of came early in her tenure in 1996
where she wrote the majority opinion
that required the virginia military
institute
to admit women the question is whether
virginia
can constitutionally deny to women
who have the will and capacity the
training and attendant opportunities
vmi uniquely affords ten years later or
so
she wrote a dissent uh in a five to four
case
called ledbetter versus a goodyear
attire my name is lily ledbetter
it is an honor to be here today to talk
about my experience
trying to enforce my right to equal pay
for equal work
i wish my story had a happy ending but
it doesn't
the five member majority throughout
lilly ledbetter's claim
justice ginsburg said the majority got
it wrong tagline in my
opinion was the ball is now in
congress's court
to correct the error into which my
colleagues have fallen we got the lilly
ledbetter fair
act it's a victory for women's groups
and a milestone for the new obama
administration
the president picked the lilly ledbetter
fair pay act as the first piece of
legislation he signed since taking
office
she became at the end of her career a
kind of uh
icon for young women in particular as
one law student made up meme
borrowing that of the late rapper
notorious b.i.g
she became framed as the notorious rbg
i think i should explain what i have in
common
with the notorious beer
there's something quite important we
were both
born and bred in brooklyn new york
[Applause]
she was someone who made a great effort
to
appear and talk to students and young
people and many many audiences
she was seen as the linchpin of the
liberal block in the supreme court at a
time when that block was shrinking and
under pressure
not just another liberal vote but the
leader of that bloc
some justices don't leave much of an
imprint through
their writing others we continue to
discuss
centuries after their passing obviously
we can't say today what her fate will be
but if people are still talking about
the notorious rbg
a century from now i wouldn't be
surprised